[Musique]
vous savez pour la décoration on a
énormément de guirlandes de boules c'est
tout du plastique alors tolérance si je
les jette ça devient l'échelle tant que
je les garde le plus longtemps possible
mais il n'empêche que je peux faire au
cours d'activités avec les enfants aussi
des décorations alors celle-ci par
exemple je sais pas si les gens qui sont
dans ma génération vous en avez fait à
l'école moi j'ai appris à faire ça à
l'école à l'époque ma fille elle connaît
pas en CE1
voilà comment est-ce qu'on s'y prend
celle-ci c'est ma fille qui est la
débuter
[Musique]
on a simplement deux morceaux de
guirlande
deux fils de la même du crépon
deux bandes de la même taille de la même
largeur et en fait
1 et puis l'autre
et on va dans l'autre sens
vous savez c'est un peu le principe des
scoubidous en quelque sorte et à force
quand je déballe je mets un petit scotch
à la fin